how's it going bros this is markiplier
here together with just a joke it was
awesome why do I feel so like the face
you want who is more likely to is what
we're doing today
Oh weird the consequences oh gee okay so
we're gonna wait I'm gonna make a
statement you guys has lift whoever you
think is more likely to i getcha and
then with most will do a consequence by
the end this is a great idea it's like
the chillest video i've ever recorded
are you comfortable
okay they're a bit weird so just go with
that all right
okay who's more likely to suck a dick
for 1 million dollars for a million
dollars or subs yeah okay dude hot dogs
I do
who is looks the best nation all right
mug is one point you do not want to lose
mark who watches the most porn if we're
talking like me a few years ago probably
no i-i've intentionally cut back who is
more likely to be a drama queen
what okay fine
who's most likely to die first yeah max
couple I can't stop going who's more
likely to murder their partner angry
aggressive man sweetheart who's more
likely to take a selfie the best Nick
it's understandable three of us yeah
pretty much
accidental bold pics it's just a matter
of time I was very very tight I did not
notice who's more likely to kiss another
man what what are you trying to tell you
that your own family thought you were
getting for a while hey no yeah okay
fine that's true but whatever
I mean I've kissed a guy before I have
to and it was horrible that's why I will
never do it again
I haven't on purpose eventually yeah oh
did you how did that kiss like turning
around somebody was there early
that did not happen mine was a game of
truth if that does not happen how
doesn't happen to me I don't even think
that Constance how does that happen to
my career I'm leaning forward lips iris
in everything like primary school - and
I was so embarrassed and everyone made
fun of me oh okay uh well it was me and
two close friends and two girls I was
like no yeah yeah girl yeah well my
friend was I wish I was sitting down I
remember I was at Bob's place and we
were all playing truth or dare I didn't
kiss Bob I kissed his friend Kristin and
so we were playing truth or dare it was
just like it was like a truth or dare
this girl would show us her boobs on
female action who's more likely to cry
during a movie likely to suck a dick to
save their YouTube channel more likely
to have a crash and burn after their
career dies for success
[Music]
you came up with the questions within
the head there someone who's most likely
to run into a burning building to save
someone who's more likely to exchange Oh
Marik's losing what why am I losing
that's one line oh wow that was the game
bringing the punishment oh haha what's
the punishment you're not gonna like
this
oh we just bought that oh I'm gonna be
so embarrassed if milk actually comes
out like this like this Romanian is
telling me that Jack got an equal amount
of points so Jack has to do is go this
is the scoring system
I had 36 I at the least on my nips
apparently to spread
[Applause]
dude that's insane I don't know if this
is worth it I don't know how to get one
I get one okay I have super-sensitive
nips
well visceral experience all right now
it's time for Oh God Jack would you do
the honors I don't think it's gonna seal
do your Gooch all right okay you hold
that one there all right well thank you
guys for coming on that's too much
fabric and like this video if you
enjoyed we're gonna I'm sure people here
with this this is working no you got if
you're gonna do it you gotta do it right
oh well thank you guys so much for
watching thanks to thanks to Felix and
so yeah thanks great thanks I got mark
playing Jack I leave a link in
description of things we're leaving a
like and as always bros we do the
brofist yes what do you do the brofist
as always as I did this is so [ __ ]
weird get a little closer mark sorry
this is how thumbnails are mate
that's cool that looks cool okay
[Music]